PROFESSOR: I've put on the
blackboard here the things
we were doing last time.
We began our study
of stationary states
that are not normalizable.
These are scattering states.
Momentum eigenstates
were not normalizable,
but now we have more
interesting states that
represent the solutions of
the Schrodinger equation, that
are stationary states
with some energy e.
Because they are
not normalizable,
but we cannot directly
interpret any of these solutions
as the behavior of a particle.
I kind of tell you a story, OK.
So this is-- a particle
is coming, colliding,
doing something.
These are not
normalizable states.
So part of what we're going
to be trying to do today
is connect to the
picture of wave packets
and see how this is
used to really calculate
what would happen if you send
in a particle of potential.
Nevertheless, we
wrote a solution
that has roughly that
interpretation, at least
morally speaking.
We think of a wave that is
coming from the left, that's
ae to the ikx.
Now, in order to
have a wave, you
would have to have
time dependents,
and this is a
stationary solution.
And there is some
time dependents.
There is exponential of e to
the minus iet over h bar, where
e is the energy.
So this could be
added here to produce
the full stationary
state psi of x and t.
But we'll leave it understood--
it's a common phase
factor for both the
solutions of x less than 0,
and x greater than 0, because
the whole solution represents
a single solution.
It's not like a
solution on the left
and a solution on the right.
It's a single solution
over all of x 4 a psi that
has some definite energy.
So we looked at the
conditions of continuity
of the wave function
and continuity
of the derivative of the
wave function, at x equals 0.
Those were two conditions.
And they gave you
this expression
for the ratios of c
over a and b over a.
We could even imagine, since
we can't normalize this,
setting a equal to 1, And.
Then calculating b and
c from those numbers.
We have two case a k in a k bar.
The k is relevant to the wave
function for x less than 0.
The k bar is relevant
for x greater than 0.
And they have to be different
because this represents
a DeBroglie wavelength, and
the DeBroglie wavelength
encodes the momentum
of the particle,
and the momentum of the
particle that we imagine here
classically is
different here where
this has this much kinetic
energy, and in the region
on the right, where
the particle only has
a much smaller kinetic energy.
So that's represented by k bar.
And k bar, being the
energy proportional
to the energy minus v 0, while
k squared has just the energy,
it's smaller than k.
So this is what we did.
We essentially
solved the problem,
and this qualifies
as a solution,
but we still haven't learned
anything very interesting
from it.
We have to understand
more what's going on.
And one thing we can do is
think of a particular limit.
The limit, or the case,
when e is equal to v 0,
exactly equal to
b 0, what happens?
Well, k bar would be equal to 0.
And if k bar is
equal to 0, you're
going to have just the
constant c in here.
But if k bar is
equal to 0, first b
is equal to a, because then it's
k over k, so b is equal to a.
And c is equal to 2a.
And the solution would
become psi of x equals--
well, a is equal to b.
So this is twice a cosine
of kx, when a equal to b
is a common factor, call it a.
And this thing is the
sum of two exponentials
with opposite signs.
That gives you the cosine.
And for c, you have 2a.
And since k bar is equal
to 0, well, it's just 2a.
It's a number.
This is unnormalizable, but
even the original solution
is unnormalizable,
so we wouldn't
worry too much about it.
So how does that
look for x over here?
You have a cosine
of kx, so it's going
to be doing this to the left.
That's for x less than 0.
And at this point,
it goes like that.
Just flat side
effects, and here's 2a.
so there's nothing wrong with
the solution in this case.
It's kind of a little strange
that it becomes a constant,
but perfectly OK.
What really helps
you here is to find
some conditions that express
the conservation of probability.
You see, you have a
stationary state solution.
Now, stationary states
are funny states.
They're not static states,
completely static states.
For example, if you have a
loop, and you have a current
that never changes in time.
This is a stationary condition,
even in electromagnetism.
So what we imagine
here is that we're
going to have some current,
probability current,
that is coming from the
left, and some of it
maybe bounces back, and
some of it goes forward.
But essentially, if you think
of the barrier, whatever--
you look a little to
the left of the barrier
and a little to the
right of the barrier.
Whatever is coming in, say,
must be going out there,
because probability cannot
increase in this region.
It would be like saying that
the particle suddenly requires
larger and larger
probability to be
in this portion of the graph.
And that can't happen.
So probabilistic
current gives you
a way to quantify some of the
things that are happening.
So probability current
plus j effects,
which was h bar over m,
imaginary part of psi star
d psi dx.
So let's compute the
probability current.
Let's compute for x less than 0.
What is the probability
current j of x?
We then call it the probability
current on the left side.
I would have to substitute
the value of the wave function
for x less than 0, which
is the top line there,
into this formula.
And see what is the current.
In fact, I believe you've
done that in an exercise
some time ago.
And as you can
imagine, the current
is proportional to the
modulus of a squared,
the length of a squared,
the length of b squared also
enters.
And the funny thing is,
between those two waves,
one that is going to the right
and one is going to the left,
that that's very
visible in the current.
This is h bar k over m.
A squared minus b squared.
It's a short computation, and it
might be an OK and a good idea
to do it again.
It was done in the homework.
And x greater than 0.
J right of x would be
equal to h bar k bar.
Now that, you can almost
do it in your head.
This c into the ik bar x.
Look what's happening.
From psi star you get a c star.
From psi you get the c, so
that's going to be a c squared.
The face is going in a
cancel between the one here
and the one on psi,
but the derivative
will bring down an ik bar,
and the imaginary part of that
is just k bar.
So the answer is this.
And these are the two currents.
Now, if we are doing
things correctly,
the two currents
should be the same.
Whatever current
exists to the left,
say a positive current that
is coming in, to the right
must be the same.
Another pleasant thing
is that this current
doesn't depend on the value
of x, as x is less than 0.
Nor of the value of x
when x is greater than 0.
And that's good
for conservation.
It would be pretty
bad as well, if you
look at two places
for x less than 0,
and you find that the
current is not the same.
So where is it accumulating?
What's going on?
So the independence
of these things--
from x, this is
constant, and a constant
is very important, because this
constant should be the same.
Now, whether or not about
current conservation,
it's encoded in
Schrodinger's equation.
And we solved
That's how we got these
relations between b, a and c
So it better be that these
two things are the same.
So Jay elsewhere--
jl, for example.
I won't put off x,
because it's just clear.
It doesn't depend on x.
1 minus b over a
squared a squared.
I'm starting to
manipulate the left one,
and see if indeed the
currents are the same.
And now, I get h bar k over m.
1 minus b over a squared.
I put the modulus squared,
but so far everything
is real in this--
k, k bar, b, a, c--
all real.
Is that right?
No complex numbers there.
So I don't have to
be that careful.
B over a squared is
k minus k bar over k
plus k bar squared a squared.
And I gfit that here, maybe.
H bar k over m.
Now what?
This is squared,
so the si, squared
passes here to the numerator
minus the difference squared,
that's going to be
a 4k k bar over k
plus k bar squared a squared.
And yes, this seems to
be working quite well.
Flip these k's-- these
two k's, flip them around.
So the answer for
jl so far is h bar,
now k bar, because
I flipped that, m,
and now I would have 4 k
squared over this thing, which
is 2k over k plus k bar
squared of a squared.
And this quantity,
if I remember right,
is just c squared, as
you can see from there.
So indeed, this is j
right, and it worked out.
This is j right.
So j left is equal to j right
by current conservation.
So that's nice.
That's another way
of getting insight
into these coefficients.
And that kind of
thing that makes you
feel that there's no
chance you got this wrong.
It all works well.